hmm goin live with thoughts on reality
let's do it everyone boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Alan Saki on super excited to be
talking about thoughts on reality this
is very interesting because I am messing
around with the TriCaster myself right
now as you guys know Ron Vegas is the
director and producer of the show so I'm
practicing cuz it's just really fun to
know how to actually use this beautiful
piece of equipment and reality is a very
very strange place in so many different
ways and probably one of the craziest
ways that reality has been tripping me
out has been I don't really know at
times what's going on like that my
consciousness is in this body and that
the earth is designed a certain way and
I'm not quite sure what to think of that
all because if your consciousness is
trapped inside of this specific flesh
vehicle that you reside in and then
reality has programmed a certain way
like the earth is a certain distance
from the star 93 million miles the earth
is a certain amount of of diameter and
actually I have something really fun to
show you right now boom mixed effects
too with Google so now I can be like you
know and so we can look things up
together and have fun Earth has an 8,000
mile diameter so so so now look at all
these weird variables right okay so
Earth's 93 million miles from the star
it's it has an 8,000 mile diameter 66
million years ago there was a X
of the dinosaurs and that asteroid that
hit helped make it so that monkeys could
evolve into humans and that we could now
find ourselves as stewards of Earth and
I find the way that civilization was
designed to be very strange like it's
weird that we have these just like
humans interact with each other in very
very strange ways like what would it be
like if we evolved on a you know on a
different planet with a different time
scale with different variables that were
being crunched like what if our you know
what if our nervous system evolved
differently what if the way that our
bodies were shaped evolved differently
or the heart evolved differently or the
other organs evolved differently what if
we weren't carbon-based life-forms coded
by DNA what if we were coded by
something else and so I'm just not I'm
not really sold on reality in the sense
that this is the only interpretation me
being locked inside my body and needing
to live in this civilization as being
like the only way to live in this
reality I know that can sound a little
trippy but I think we can get past the
trippy sounding this of that by thinking
about the like you know what happens
when you go into deep profound
experiences of like tuning in word
through maybe it's meditation or maybe
it's maybe it's psychedelics those have
been totally our go twos recently for
trying to augment people's perception
make it more nuanced as the famous look
from the TEDx talk it was so funny our
perception is nuanced its multivariate
most people are either pro or against
immigration but if you find the nuance
the multi variability you can find a
cool position like being a Xena file
pragmatist which means that you love
foreign cultures but you want to be
pragmatic at the border
just funny funny ways of of expressing
oneself and and you know I just I feel
so like I feel so real and raw and
myself when I when I'm when I'm here in
my conscious in this in this body with
this consciousness but then I then I
like do meditation or ice I do
psychedelics and I and I go deep within
my body and then I go deep within all of
reality and what do I mean by that I
mean like I don't know traveling outside
of the body and into other star systems
and other realities outside of this
universe and maybe into other
multiverses where you can experience
yourself in different lives like when I
think of myself I think of myself
splitting into different lives all the
time because I had this constant
neurological stress that had been going
on the last couple of years you know
most people don't know these things
about me and I'll try and do more of
these little thoughts on reality or
whatever sessions of like getting to
know Allen a little bit better more
intimately and here you can see a little
bit more fun you know we can get a
little more intimate if you want I can
get a little zoom ski on the eyes all
right so I'll do more of these because I
think they're I think they're really fun
for everyone that watches to to just get
to know me a little bit better and get
to know what these ideas that I'm
communicating and synthesizing from
other brilliant people are that way you
know what you're getting yourself into
more so so a lot of people don't know
this about me but I I I've had a lot of
I guess stress throughout my life with
you know being pulled apart for pulled
away from entrepreneurship a lot and you
know what do I mean by that well I've
had I moved out here when I was 19 and I
said that in the who are we video and
when I moved out here to Silicon Valley
were based in San Francisco and I moved
from Sioux Falls in Minneapolis in the
middle of the United States and so when
I moved out here I knew that I wanted to
pursue entrepreneurship that I wanted uh
surround myself with all these brilliant
people out here I knew that I knew the
strength of the nodes that were building
the future and I wanted to be close to
them I knew what I was doing but I
didn't know it was gonna be this hard
and so because of that I've had this
constant pull in my I envisioned Allen
that stayed in Sioux Falls or the Allen
that stayed in Minneapolis and what that
Allen would be doing and I personally
don't think it would be as fulfilling so
I'm happy I'm in this multiverse where
I'm pursuing San Francisco but when I
was 22 when I was 23 when I was 24 even
lost 25 I'm 26 now that every single
year out here in San Francisco I've
pretty much had this thought of like get
out of San Francisco and why am I
talking about wanting to get out of San
for this school because it when you
pursue entrepreneurship you trap
yourself in entrepreneurship for like a
decade at least because as soon as
you're at you're in the TEDx talk it
gave attention is the most valuable
commodity so that means that if you're
only awake 16 hours a day you sleep
eight hours of the day that there's a
hundred twenty billion collective hours
of attention on the planet you yourself
have 16 of those hours every single day
the every ounce and droplet of minutes
and seconds that you spend on your
business that you're trying to build
into the world you're trying to build
value into the world the better your
business does and the less time you
spend on your business the more time you
spend doing things like going out and
drinking or going and and and
and browsing through your echo chamber
of a newsfeed whatever it may be that
these sorts of distractions that we have
that we don't even realize are
distractions from our full creative
potential that that those distractions
are that that's how other people make
money that's exactly what they try and
do they try and reel you in with alcohol
addiction and reel you in with news feed
addictions and they reel you in with all
these different things that take away
from your creative endeavoring so when
you when when when I see when I saw
myself in San Francisco and I was like
okay this is really [ __ ] hard
pursuing an entrepreneurship I have to
do this day and night day and night day
and night and you just saw this I mean
this literally just happened you know no
you know people say it's like a [ __ ]
famous quote now no free plugs no free
plugs we're gonna send you an invoice
for our plug but I'm just gonna go ahead
and say it it's interesting to see these
Jen's II kids pulling up like Joe Josie
WA and one moment I have I'm gonna I
think I need to rewind my my VHS
cassette yeah I'm rewinding my VHS
cassette they shout out to Ron vaughese
for having an OG set where he still has
a VHS player I love it it's so great
takes me back all right so Joe Joshua
very interesting 15 and a half year old
multi-millionaire she's crazy
interesting super bubbly personality the
only reason I was introduced to her was
because I checked out logan Paul's
podcast called impulsive and I've done a
couple episodes on logan Paul's
eccentricity in his maverick tendencies
and I think in just in general I think
those sorts of tendencies are actually
extremely good for civilization and they
can go it can go too far like we saw
with the forest thing but he had Joe Joe
I thought that was very interesting and
so I learned about her and I saw this
you know like 15 and a half year old and
that's just building the future and I
saw these you know who how many of us
watching right now
like fifteen and a half and selling 40
million bows at Target and and
headphones at Best Buy and and she has
all these different product lines and
stuff and she's a Nickelodeon star and
all this other kind of stuff you know
her she's got like I don't know billion
views on her channel already it's just
craziness and this is the future this is
where we are this is where we're going
that these kids these Jen's II kids
understand where civilization is going
and they are building it with content
content being king so I circle back to
content being king and just a quick
segue think about what it's like to grow
up as a Jen's II kid in China where as a
Jen's II kid in Russia or a Gen Z kid in
South Africa or in the Middle East or in
Brazil like think about what it's like
in these different places on the planet
because they have different ways that
these kids are growing up so I bring
this up because you know she's talking
about how she hustles day and night
right she does a day a night she goes
like 8 a.m. to 8 p.m. at Nickelodeon
shooting and she has to come back and
put together a daily vlog and and go and
shoot that and edit it and push it out
and you know what it's interesting
because now she's collected a little bit
of experience over time and for those
you know for those that don't know you
know I'm gonna show you right now here's
uh here's who Jojo is Jojo sua I'm
showing you right now here's her here's
her you know here's some pictures of her
she's again she's just this extremely
like bubbly youthful spirit extremely
extroverted and she's got this you know
this is her famous like bow line right
she sells these bows all over the
interwebs and all over retail and so
that's one of her like product lines
anyway so she's 15 and a half it's nuts
at the time of this recording in
November of 2018 and like her her
channel like you go to her channel right
these are this is this is the future I'm
literally showing you the future right
now that this is what's going on
in the world I'm actually gonna hook
Jojo see what up with the subscribe I
hadn't done that yet but I watched this
video called dream in this you know she
speaks you know this video dream of hers
has 11 million views in two weeks nuts
and it also is just like holy [ __ ] like
she talks about very inspirational stuff
in this video she's talking about dream
fulfilling your dream she's talking to
these other super young kids about
seeing their dream and becoming that
dream and that's really obviously very
inspirational we talk about that all the
time on the show build the future going
rebirth the public intellectual manifest
your destiny into the world etc and
she's doing it for the youth I think she
said that her average subscriber is
between the ages of like 2 and 14 when I
heard that I was like what two and three
and four-year-olds are using YouTube
that's freaking crazy and obviously
Target and all these big conglomerates
that are retail and they care about
LTV which means lifetime value of these
young kids and they want to have
audiences like jojo's because then
whatever Jojo markets these two and 14
year olds will start seeing the product
placements in their attention in their
eyeballs and that that idea again is
it's about attentions about the
attention economy that's why Logan
started impulsive his podcast is vodcast
that's why that's why you saw you know
Eric we just did a show Eric Weinstein
was on Geoghan Joe Rogan show and Eric
wines one of the smartest public
intellectuals alive today and we just
did a thoughts on that episode and you
know Eric started a YouTube channel Eric
started a YouTube channel and he started
and oh I should play this now let's give
this a play boom look at that oh gee
that og TV it's so interesting look at
this oh gee black and away film
all right back back at it so so alright
so think about this
Eric Eric started
an Instagram account and you know that's
why he started an Instagram account cuz
he's trying to get to more people he
understands that that's how to get to
more people that content is king in this
sense and so he's doing that and he got
to like ten cave followers in like a
couple of weeks or something it was very
interesting network effects are really
insane here - I'll get to where this and
makes neurological distress in my life
in a moment I know I'm in a full circle
back to that don't worry I'll get there
that that there's this network effects
are starting to take over Logan
announced impulsive made a YouTube page
and with no videos he had a hundred and
fifty thousand subs he has an Instagram
account for his dog Kong you know this
is I mean like watch this watch this I'm
gonna I'm about to show you some again
network effects stuff so you go here and
you go to so if you look up Kong to
savage Instagram and look it look at
this logan Paul's [ __ ] dog has 3.1
million followers now you know you know
you get where I'm going with this I want
you to I want you to get where I'm going
with this this this again no free plugs
I'm an invoice you Logan
but but I got no subscribers there's
nothing to invoice for now but it's so
funny because it's this is nuts that you
know his Logan now has a secondary
account called Kong to savage the Kong
doesn't own this account Logan does and
it's a 3.1 million follower account that
has a lot of this followings obviously
logan paul's following but there are
some people that don't follow logan that
follow what is it Pomeranian right this
dog and so there are people that just
follow animals that are following the
stalk it's just interesting how this is
working in logan has another account
I believe it's Pearl Bingbing this is
pig's name
and so watch this watch this
yeah look at this pearl Bingbing almost
500k followers oh do I not follow either
one okay I'll give Kong to Savage and
pearl Bingbing a follow fine all right I
mean look at how do you know follow that
but anyway um look at this pearl
Bingbing five hundred thousand followers
and and this is again this is crazy now
he has three accounts he has another
account is fine which Kate Fox you get
how the network effect works right in
you know he pushed two more episodes out
of impulsive and though after those two
more episodes on impulsive he has like
four hundred thousand subs now on
YouTube so I'm just saying the network
effect is real and the ones that have
attention keep getting more and more
attention
I think Jojo see we got I'm gonna get
back to neurological distress in a
moment Jojo see wha
got this really interesting advice from
Gwen Stefani Gwen Stefani's advice for
Jojo SIA was keep your clothes on damn
that's some [ __ ] good advice good
[ __ ]
that's lit that's really good advice
that might be some of the best advice
that fifteen and a half year old has
ever heard in her life so um stuff like
that's really really interesting alright
let's get back to this neurological
distress follow the network effects
watch what's going on in the podcast
vodcast space watch what's going on in
the attention economy and I mean watch
like a hawk on the attention economy and
go I'm gonna I'm gonna plug the TEDx
talk that that I gave in San Francisco
and the art of powerful questions I
touched on the attention economy and the
importance of that go check that out
it's um on Alan Sakyong calm but also
I'll link to it in the bio here alright
yo back to this neurological distress so
why the hell am i mentioning all this
stuff because this girl Jojo see what
works hella hard Logan works hella hard
I work hella hard but this is
interesting because on entrepreneur has
to work this hard in order for them to
get attention and to get followers and
to get to their breakthrough
in what they're trying to build into the
world again this is a lot of what I
talked to on the TEDx talk so so
reality's a very crazy place because I
don't think that I always live in this
universe I frequently venture out to
when I was 22 23 24 25 I was constantly
being pulled out to go to China to go to
a Europe to go to New York to go to
these different places and what